I want today to talk about,
um,
the industrial revolution from a variety of,
uh,
of aspects.
I put everything on the board I put on our website.
So don't worry about copying it down and it's all pretty,
pretty obvious.
So a doing an industrial revolution,
uh,
across the century is no easy task,
but we will do it.
And,
um,
do the reading.
Let me just say that to the way people look at what used to be called industrial
revolution and I guess some people still call it.
That has changed dramatically,
um,
through the 1950s and end of the 1960s.
The idea of the industrial revolution was that,
uh,
it was the work of some genius.
He and ventures who created a mechanism mech machines in the,
uh,
use primarily in the textile industry,
but also in mining that,
uh,
eliminated blocks to assembly line production.
And then everybody was crowded into factories and,
and the new brave world opened up.
Um,
and we'll fact,
one of the most interesting books instead of great classics is still in print,
was written by an economic historian at Harvard who's still around called David
Landis,
a good book called the unbound Prometheus's was,
which was basically that.
And some of the inventions that I briefly described in your,
in your reading,
the spinning Jenny,
et Cetera,
uh,
refer to that.
Well,
and then the,
that kind of,
um,
analysis led one to concentrate on,
on England where the industrial revolution,
uh,
began.
Uh,
and to view an interview industrialization as being a situation of,
of a,
of so winners and,
and,
and uh,
and losers by not going as fast.
Uh,
in,
in your reading.
I give you some,
uh,
pretty obvious examples of reasons for the industrial revolution.
First coming to to England,
uh,
location of,
of,
uh,
resources,
particularly coal,
a country which there's nowhere this 75% more than 75 miles away from the sea,
uh,
for cautious canals and roads,
a banking system,
fluid fluidity between classes.
Um,
uh,
a very large,
an increasingly larger proletariat,
uh,
agricultural revolution,
et cetera.
Uh,
and with that kind of analysis,
those places that didn't industrial as fast,
uh,
industrialized as fast,
for example,
France.
So one thought,
well,
uh,
that they were quote unquote retarded,
a word that was used,
unfortunately at that time.
And then one tried to see why,
why not?
Now that analysis has been really a rejected,
uh,
greatly over,
over,
over the past years because,
uh,
um,
industrial evolution is measured by more than simply large,
uh,
factories,
with industrial,
uh,
workers,
and,
uh,
the number of machines.
And the more,
and this is the point of the beginning of this,
the more that we look at the industrial revolution,
uh,
the more that we see that industrial revolution was first and foremost,
and intensification of forms of production,
of kinds of production that were already there.
And thus,
we spend more time looking at,
you know,
the intensification of artisanal production,
craft production of domestic industry,
which we've already mentioned that his people,
uh,
mostly women,
but also men and children to working in the countryside.
Uh,
and that,
uh,
that industrial,
the,
the rapid rise of,
of,
of a industrial production,
uh,
was very much a tied to traditional forms of,
of production.
Uh,
in Paris for example,
uh,
at the,
in 1871 or [inaudible] 1870,
only the average unit of production had only little,
slightly more than seven people in it.
Um,
so if you only look for big factories and lots of machines,
uh,
you'll be missing the boat on.
Um,
uh,
I'm the industrial revolution now to be sure when we think of the industrial
revolution,
we think of Manchester,
which grew from a very small town into,
into this enormous,
uh,
city full of,
of what angles called the satanic mills of industrial production.
Or you think of smoking Sheffield,
uh,
also in,
in,
uh,
in northern England.
Or you think of Birmingham in the,
in the Midlands.
And if you think of France,
you'll think of Lille,
and it's to a burgeoning and towns around it to a client who bay,
or you think of Santa Tn,
which was kind of Francis Manchester or in Germany.
You think of,
uh,
of the Rhineland and their war.
Uh,
and in Italy you think of of Turin and Milan,
uh,
and in,
in,
in Russia,
you think of the Moscow and Saint Peter's per region or in Spain,
Barcelona.
And indeed,
those are sorts of,
those are classic cases of industrial concentration where you do have,
you know,
a really significant mechanization over a very long period of time.
And you do have large towns with smokey factories full of,
of,
of workers.
But,
but again,
uh,
this,
and we've underestimated,
I in fact,
the second edition has more about this and the first of what you're reading a,
you know,
the,
the degree of industrial production in the late Russian empire.
Um,
but,
but yet,
uh,
to be sure when I say that the,
that the industrial revolution is first and foremost an intensification of forms
of,
of industry that already existed.
Uh,
if you were,
you know,
if you are a parachutist and you somehow floating down over the European,
uh,
over Europe,
from say the middle of the 18th century through the middle of the 19th century,
what you would see is that there were still all sorts of industry,
a rapid increase of industrial production that is out in the countryside,
does not in factories.
This done in a very traditional where w way,
uh,
or rural handicraft people producing all sorts of things,
you know,
still at home.
And there's just a marvelous book written by a woman called Maxine Burg,
a,
B e r,
g,
a who teaches at,
um,
at,
uh,
where did you teach,
in the north of England someplace that will come to me in a minute,
um,
called the age of manufacturer and she reexamined even the industrial revolution
and discovered that for example,
the town of Birmingham,
which produced all sorts of toys,
big toy manufacturers,
that you still,
even though you had a lot of factories,
you still had a lot of the toys are being finished or even produced by women
working in the hinterland.
That is the payee payee or the,
the,
uh,
the environs of Birmingham.
Or if you take a Sheffield,
smokey,
Sheffield,
a grim,
uh,
a grim kind of place in the 19th century where they produce knives and cutlery.
You still had a lot of these products being finished by people out in the
countryside.
Or if you take the north of France,
if you think of a town like harass,
r e I,
m s,
famous for Champagne,
uh,
if you take class,
you know,
it was a big industrial center of,
but it wasn't a center of,
of,
of mechanize production until after about 1850.
What you had is you have all these people out in the countryside,
mostly women who are doing spinning and weaving and karting and that kind of
thing.
Or around Nasi,
which is a town in the east of France.
Um,
you,
it,
by 1875,
you still had something like 75,000 women who are embroiderers working in the
countryside.
I in rural industry,
you know,
it,
it intensifies.
And then finally at the end,
what you have is this sort of,
not at the end,
but it depends on where you are.
You have this implosion,
implosion of work into factories.
Uh,
and so by the end of the century,
that kind of traditional,
uh,
I view that one would have of the industrial revolution has really has really
arrived,
were,
were factory production and above all in the textile industry,
the textile industry is the leading edge of the industrial revolution,
the textile industry.
Um,
and that you have women who used to work,
you know,
at home,
uh,
and are now working,
in,
uh,
in factories as what the British call a textile operatives or Switzerland.
You sent,
what to think of,
you know,
you think of Switzerland and you know,
as being the famous mercenaries in the early modern period or the very wealthy
bankers,
you know,
in our own day.
Uh,
but if you look at it,
think of a town like Zurich,
Zurich on the lake.
Uh,
there was all sorts of industry in the,
with the up lands of,
of Zurich that has,
you know,
up into the hills and up even into the mountains around Zurich,
uh,
of a,
of a handicraft production or Austria in Austria,
Guerin empire,
Austria.
Also,
you know,
there's,
there's hundreds of thousands of,
of people working in the textile industry.
So the details aren't as important as the fact that to be sure you know,
the minds that you'll read about in Jeremy now.
Anyway,
it was just a great,
great read.
Uh,
uh,
and,
and the factories that I will describe in a while or described by a angles,
and I couldn't do better than that.
Uh,
you know,
our reality and they become,
the industrial experience.
And when you think of,
you know,
Detroit,
Michigan in the 1930s or Flint,
Michigan in the 1930s,
or you think about,
uh,
you know,
all the is now the rust belt of Connecticut,
uh,
of Torrington and these places that were once booming industrial towns.
You know,
that's the kind of classic model.
And the American model really is closer to what people used to think,
what the industrial revolution met in,
uh,
the case of,
of Europe.
But that's a,
you know,
not a subject for now,
but a couple of points a long the way.
I don't think I'll ever get to my notes,
but it doesn't really matter.
Um,
uh,
first of all,
and this is another reason why the industrial revolution starts in England.
You can't have an industrial revolution without an agricultural revolution.
Um,
and because what the agriculture revolution does is increases the amount of food
produced.
You know,
this is going to feed your sort of burgeoning proletariat,
your labor force.
And this is a place,
you know,
all of Europe increases in population.
The French population is unique.
It stops growing in 1846 and 47.
It's simply stops,
skids to a halt,
but everywhere else the population grows.
And there are regional differences in France as there are regional differences
everywhere.
But the industrial revolution,
uh,
is,
depends on the agricultural revolution for a increase in food supply.
Uh,
this makes it possible,
uh,
the increase in urban population,
thus also increasing the,
the,
the demand for food,
uh,
and also the agricultural revolution particularly,
but not just in the case of England,
uh,
increases capital formation of that.
You've got this sort of surplus of money,
bucks,
pounds,
Prune your own cash that can be invested in industry.
And this is precisely what happens.
So that's why the agriculture revolution I is,
is absolutely important.
And so these three things,
industrial revolution,
agricultural revolution and the growth of cities are very much tied together.
Let me give you an example,
which you certainly don't have to remember,
but,
but you know,
think of Manchester,
Manchester.
I mean,
I described the statistics in there that they're absolutely the growth and
Manchester is a prodigious scary thing.
And I'll talk more about how a rural and urban elites are a frightened by the
growth of cities,
uh,
particularly in Germany,
in France and England and in the United States later.
What the growth of Manchester does is it really changes the countryside around
and helps bring the agricultural revolution.
What are,
I mean by that?
You find the same thing around Paris or Ron Berlin or around Warsaw almost at
any big city that I can think of is you've got in response to this urban growth,
this,
this big of octopus of people and money of rich people and poor people will talk
about some of the rich people next time on Wednesday.
Uh,
you've got an,
you've got an expand for demand for food.
And so in that ring immediately around a city like Manchester,
you've got a dramatic expansion of,
of people doing what they called truck farming.
You know,
they're producing,
they're specializing in crops,
uh,
for the urban market,
fruit,
vegetables,
things like that.
They specialize because there's people there.
They're going to pay for an eat what they produce.
Uh,
you know,
take a,
the example of Paris or a come back and talk about with great relish some day.
Um,
uh,
that in the suburbs of Paris,
a place called,
it doesn't matter at all.
I've called Molokai,
which is,
which is a kind of a grim part of,
of,
of eastern Paris.
I used to be famous for his cherries and fruits and that kind of thing that
they're producing for the urban market or wine.
If you can imagine winding produced.
What a horrible idea.
Uh,
uh,
in the region of Paris.
Well,
it's a in,
yeah.
Which is,
uh,
you know,
on the San River used to produce wine for this urban market.
Then the next big ring around Manchester,
you've got,
you've got the big fish eating the little fish,
and so they're more productive,
more uh,
uh,
his commercial agriculture develops and more productive,
production.
That's a terrible sentence.
Uh,
more a greater productivity for a in response to this urban demand.
And then the,
on the far distant places,
you have people specializing in the production of cattle that has milk and meat
for,
for the market.
And of course,
the other thing which goes without saying is that in the course of the 19th
century,
you've got this,
you know,
amazing development in,
in,
in shipping.
Because,
you know,
pretty soon with steel and with the refrigeration and you've got,
you've got,
you've got just like now you've got lamb arriving from New Zealand and things
like that.
And this is largely in response to the increase of,
uh,
you know,
of these large urban it conurbations that we used the term conurbation to,
uh,
to,
to describe a cities that grew up so much that the act actually,
you know,
merge together.
Uh,
and all of that.
I mean,
the American,
uh,
northeast became a sort of a conurbation and then it's very hard to,
we went through New Jersey to ever see where there aren't cities cause one ends
and then the other starts.
And that becomes the case in,
in,
in parts of northern England,
uh,
as well.
So,
um,
the term prodo industrialization,
there,
uh,
is what we mean by the expansion of a industrial production along very
traditional lines.
And what I put in parentheses there,
domestic or rural industry we already talked about.
So this,
the first you've got this expansion of industry,
uh,
in the countryside.
And I'll give you one example.
Again,
I hate to keep taking examples occasionally from France,
but because I know knowing that best,
but the city of [inaudible],
which is a big soap,
uh,
producing,
city,
what you have is you've got an a in the first half of the 19th century,
you've got an implosion of work into the y'all,
into this working class suburb of Leon called the Dakota hosts.
It doesn't matter.
Um,
though it's a neat place.
It's a really neat place.
Um,
and then in the 1850s,
the people that own the silk begin to put work back out into the countryside.
Why would they do that?
Because the women working there,
or the man working there worked for less than people living in the city.
So this again,
if you're parachuting down,
uh,
starting about 1750,
you're going to see this.
You have to imagine,
you know,
tens or hundreds of thousands of little dots out in the countryside.
A and even more of them as the industrial revolution gets kicking along before
you finally have this implosion or movement in and around cities.
More about that.
When I talk about cities,
uh,
and,
and I to help explain why European cities are so different than American cities
with the poor living on the outside and the rich living within and,
and,
and large scale industrialization has a lot to do with that.
Now,
having said all of that,
let me talk a little bit about on there.
We'll get there my notes.
But,
uh,
this is fun.
Anyway.
Uh,
let me talk a little bit about women's work now.
Did the Industrial Revolution Change Women's work?
Well,
they're continuity's in women's work,
which are extremely important.
And ultimately there'll be changes as factory production,
uh,
comes to a dominate in many places in industrial Europe.
Um,
yet there's certain things that don't change about women's work and women's role
in the household.
Um,
uh,
that women remain,
the head of the family economy,
that women,
whether they're married or simply,
you know,
living,
living with people that they've been living with for a short or a long time run
the family economy.
And it's true whether they are in,
uh,
in rural,
rural Switzerland and the uplands of Zurich working in the textile industry or
whether they are a textile operatives in Manchester or someplace like that.
Um,
the industrial revolution does not change other aspects of women's work,
uh,
in that,
at least,
well into the 19th century in most parts of industrial work,
uh,
industrial Europe,
women are still working in the countryside,
but also major,
uh,
employers of women.
Uh,
I don't change at all with industrialization on the classic case here too is,
is England and that is domestic service,
domestic service.
If you are going to take England in say 1850,
the largest three categories of people doing anything are not in this order.
Uh,
but just about all of the same,
the same number,
uh,
would be,
um,
uh,
women working as domestics.
Well,
let me say,
just really?
Yeah.
Okay.
Women working as domestics,
uh,
or some went,
men worked as domestics to say domestic service,
uh,
say textile operatives and,
and an important category that I'm going to talk about about later and in my
theme of it's bitter hard to write the history of remainders,
a rural agricultural laborers,
rural proletarians,
and then another category of,
of women's work.
Um,
again,
which one,
when hesitates to evoke that,
of course,
prostitution,
uh,
and the industrial revolution here,
it,
it doesn't change that sad aspect of women's work.
What it does is increases with urban growth,
the number of people working as prostitutes,
uh,
in even very,
very small towns,
the number of prostitutes in Paris or London,
or simply incalculable.
Uh,
uh,
the estimates in Paris go from a 20,000 to 100,000.
Uh,
and lots of,
of,
of women,
uh,
were,
who were married become prostitutes,
uh,
pool affair,
Stefan do Duwan to,
to,
uh,
pay off the bills at the end of the month.
And,
and so this sad aspect of,
of,
uh,
women's,
work,
uh,
people,
forced into prostitution by,
uh,
by want,
it doesn't really change with industrialization,
uh,
into the numbers simply get a bigger and bigger.
And of course,
one of the results of this isn't the time to discuss this,
but,
but there's,
there's a social sort of panic at the end of the 19th century,
you know,
about syphilis and about venereal disease and,
and,
and all of that.
And,
and,
uh,
um,
also,
which ironically helps further,
uh,
condemn ordinary people in elite minds,
which is a very,
you know,
coincidence as many of the patrol or many of the clients have of prostitutes
were a middle class males.
And no matter what country you're talking about,
um,
more about women's work,
uh,
in a,
in a while now,
um,
in the context of factories.
Now here's again,
w you know,
history has its history too.
And when I,
uh,
you know,
grew up the extent I ever did,
uh,
in my,
um,
in,
you know,
as a,
as a student,
I mean,
back when I,
when I was thinking about you're doing a dissertation and becoming an historian
and all that stuff,
what people studied was reason I put it in quote was working class
consciousness.
And we were sort of children of,
uh,
you know,
of the very later,
the sixties or the seventies.
And,
and everybody wanted to follow the great English a story.
And he p Thompson who wrote a monumental book called the,
uh,
the making of the English working class and everybody wanted to find the making
of class conscious workers,
uh,
in various places.
Uh,
and everybody wanted to study the crowd as in the crowd and the French
revolution.
My late has a friend George Rudy's days famous book,
the crowd here or the crowd there.
And the first article I ever published was called the crowd and the affair to
the Moje April 27th,
1848.
And now I look back sometimes and things.
So,
I mean,
who cares?
But anyway,
um,
in the 19,
uh,
eighties,
then the move kind of turned away from that.
And,
and the more people starting,
uh,
starting in the middle class,
more about the middle class folk in the 19th century and what my friend Peter
Gay called the burr bourgeois century,
uh,
next time,
next time around.
But nonetheless,
uh,
you can't throw out the baby with the bath water and,
and,
uh,
class remains a fundamental concept.
If you're going to understand a 19th century Europe in 20 century Europe,
you have to under understand a social class because it was a reality.
Uh,
you know,
we live in a country now where people,
people like the sink,
there's there,
there are no classes,
uh,
well don't get me going on the current economic,
a crisis.
Uh,
and you know,
I can,
I can remember,
uh,
people going down to the Ford plants in,
in the Ypsilanti and Detroit and trying to get,
trying to get people to work in those places interested in the,
in the war against the war in Vietnam.
Uh,
and getting absolutely nowhere.
And No,
and the hearing arguments that know in America,
we don't have classes where that simply isn't true.
But anyway,
in the 19th century,
um,
uh,
social class was,
was it was a real thing and nobody was more,
had nobody had a stronger class identity then the middle class.
And that's what I'm going to talk about next time.
I can hardly wait.
Um,
but,
uh,
what we call a,
I mean,
there wasn't working class,
but not everybody saw themselves as workers,
uh,
you know,
as a form of identity as opposed to something else.
I mean,
people can have multiple identities.
When we talk about nationalism,
that's an obvious point to make.
I mean,
people,
if you ask people who they are,
they might say they're Protestant or they're Jewish or they're Catholic or
they're Muslim,
uh,
or they might say they're from this extended family or they're from this region
that they're Bavarian or,
or,
uh,
you know,
from [inaudible] or whatever.
Uh,
but in the 19th century class a class identity,
uh,
the sense of being workers as a class apart was a reality.
I mean that,
that's just the way it is.
Um,
and that was worth studying and people did some very good work on it and it's
kind of come back to it.
It's Kinda,
it's Kinda come back.
Um,
and,
um,
you know,
I mean anyone who's,
who's been in Britain,
uh,
we're,
you know,
class identity is so revealed by language.
I mean,
there isn't any place I,
including France,
uh,
or any place else that I know,
where a difference in accent or so revealing as to who,
not only who you are,
where you're from,
uh,
but,
what,
who you are in terms of social class.
And so it's really just,
uh,
just amazing.
[inaudible] it remains true in France and,
and some other places there was,
there was a strangler,
there's always the stranglers Iran in Britain.
And there was one guy who was this sort of a hardcore killer,
bad guy killing a bunch of people,
but 15 years ago.
And they finally,
they get all these experts on language and,
and he'd called up,
I guess a radio station server.
Here I am,
come and get me kind of thing.
And they had him pegged where he was within something like 10 miles of where
they ended up arresting,
which was in Bradford,
in the north of,
uh,
north of England.
So Latin languages is one of,
you know,
one of the ways that people reveal their class.
But in the 19th century we're talking about,
we're talking about workers and how some workers but not all began to see
themselves as proletarians.
Uh,
and that seems like one of those trendy words,
but it meant something to people.
Proletarian is somebody dependent on their own labor,
usually unskilled or semiskilled,
uh,
in order to,
in order to survive.
Um,
and there are two aspects to the term proletarian ization.
One is kind of the objective sense,
uh,
that you are,
you are a laborer.
Uh,
you may be a harvester,
you may pick grapes for the wine harvest.
Uh,
you may be a carrying around a large boxes,
which is what I did at Ellis loves jams and jellies in Portland,
Oregon,
uh,
or a Kellogg's of battle creek where I also work a totally unskilled.
Uh,
but,
but again,
that would not be,
that was not going to be my lifelong identity because I was able to go on to,
uh,
do something else.
But in,
in,
in Europe,
you were,
you were born into the proletariat.
Um,
for,
in most cases,
uh,
if you grew up as a Catholic,
you in,
in this part of France,
you would have still been in practicing Catholic,
uh,
a Catholic guy,
a young boy or young young girl,
young woman in,
um,
in and around San tn or in Lille,
the chances were overwhelming that you were going to follow your parents into
the minds.
You are going to go into the minds as a matter of fact,
not say again,
I hate giving these French examples,
but,
but there's an expression that's really only use there that I've ever heard.
When a kid screws up,
you know,
does something not supposed to and,
and what they say is a deuce amend as Susan Ben,
Ben,
which is if you spend two weeks,
you know,
ducking down like this and having to help guide this cart full of coal up and
down the railroad tracks,
you won't screw up like that again.
A little boy.
Uh,
and you know,
the,
the sense of,
uh,
you know,
you were born into the world of work now in America,
there were all of these kinds of literature,
the equivalent of boy's life about,
you know,
remarkable a sense into,
into the social stratosphere.
You know,
uh,
that America was the land of opportunity.
Will America was the land of opportunity,
uh,
to be sure,
and with the availability of land,
but,
but you know,
the,
uh,
cases of social mobility,
we're actually a fairly limited,
and this was certainly the case in,
in,
in almost all of Europe,
you were,
you know,
you were essentially born into for most people into this,
the status.
Now,
the other thing that happened and this explains,
it explains the rise of,
of class consciousness is that people who suddenly the bottom drops out of their
economic life.
It's a prayer,
fairly appropriate,
uh,
analogy for today.
Um,
who were artisans who are craftsmen,
uh,
become really the first,
depending on where we're talking about,
it begins really about the turn of the century that is 1800 slightly before but
mostly afterward by 1830 in England.
And then follows in other countries in,
in many,
many places where artisans and craftsmen are really the first to see themselves
as a class apart,
not unskilled workers.
Why?
I mean this is a pretty obvious artisans and craftsmen are educated up to a
point.
They have a sense of dignity about their trades.
They have organizations,
they have mutual aid societies for example or other,
uh,
you know,
there's a craft guild organization in France called would confine you
acknowledge this came from the medieval times when they built the big cathedrals
and all of that.
Uh,
they have organization,
they have a sense of pride in craft dignity.
Now,
Karl Marx,
who was pretty smart guy,
he got a lot of things wrong,
but it got a lot of things right.
Um,
Karl Marx wrote in the 19 and the 1830s and forties about how workers wages were
declining.
Well,
he was right for artisans.
There's no question about it.
And artisans are at the forefront of every single social and political movement
that you can think of.
Uh,
and the French revolution.
There we go.
Who,
who stormed the bus?
T was artisans,
uh,
1830 and France,
1848 in,
in Austria,
uh,
in Berlin,
in Paris.
Uh,
it was artisans.
Now why all of a sudden that they get mad?
Well,
there's really two reasons,
two things that happen to artisans that that caused their economic situation to
go down hill.
First of all,
the French revolution or the effects of the French revolution,
destroy the Gills.
Now,
anybody can be a Taylor or a shoemaker or whatever,
a glass maker if you,
you know,
if,
if you learn the skills,
there's no one going to say,
ah,
you can't get in this union.
You might not be able to get it in this mutual aid society or friendly society,
but you can't do the work because the guilds are gone.
The French revolution,
you know,
banishes the guilds,
free,
uh,
economic free,
laissez faire,
Adam Smith,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And their law laws against unions,
uh,
strikes are not illegal in France,
are not legal in France till 1864.
The corporation acts are reinforced by the fear in Britain of the French
revolution.
But what happens is you've got what can be called bill sule is called at that a
friend of mine in Chicago,
uh,
the crisis of expansion.
You've got all these people now who say,
Hey,
I'm going to be a tailor to,
and if you lived in Berlin or someplace in the 1840 as you would here,
Taylor's walking along the street with,
with pushing carts full of clothes that they had made from the beginning to the
end of suits being sold for practically nothing.
Why?
Because there's so many other people making suits as well.
And also mechanize production means that you can buy suits off the rack and
they're getting very little for their suits.
They didn't wake up and think,
Geez,
I can't remember how to make a suit.
They got these suits.
They can make them and they can't sell them and their wages are declining.
Are they mad?
They're furious.
Who Do they blame?
They blame the state and they blame the bourgeoisie,
the middle classes,
the middlemen.
For example,
in the case of tailors there a lot of middlemen who've got capital.
So what do you do?
You say,
look,
I'm going to get a bunch of suits made and here hear all these tailors.
They don't have enough to work.
I'm giving you a really good example because I don't know a damn thing about
about being a tailor,
but they said,
okay,
you guys do the sleeves,
all you do the sleeves,
you guys do the pants cause you can do them all one after another and don't have
to worry about doing the rest of it.
Then I'll pick up everything that you make.
So this is a continuation of rural industry,
and then I will sell it in the markets,
uh,
in the,
into the middle of the 19th century.
I know I'm into to the World War One.
You still had single women in Paris now chained to their sewing machine.
Not Literally,
but they've got to pay off the sewing machine after a sewing machine starts
before electricity.
But after Trissy comes along and they're working by themselves,
not their day isn't cut short anymore by that,
by the end of daylight,
it's cut short by sure fatigue and producing these goods,
uh,
for this market.
And so these tailors and shoemakers and all of that,
they're in every single movement and they are the ones who first say,
hey,
you know what?
All we workers,
we got some stuff in common and this is,
this is amplified by residential patterns,
people living in and around where they work,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
and mechanization also give you an example that I do know something about,
which is porcelain.
Uh,
you know,
porcelain is one of these products as a luxury good.
Renoir,
the great painter,
he started out,
he was born in Limos,
France in 1841.
[inaudible] he starts out painting plates,
he paints plates.
Now along comes this new,
uh,
technological innovation.
You know,
how you,
if you,
if you did,
and I only did very briefly,
I make,
you know,
those model airplanes and stuff like that.
And there was a little decals that you'd stick on the,
on the plane to represent the Spitfire or whatever,
American fighters,
boats.
I'm not federal war guy.
Uh,
I stopped that pretty,
uh,
pretty quick.
Um,
and so,
um,
somebody in advanced,
one of these things,
these,
these decals that can be baked on,
on the high quality plates between the first and second baking,
porcelain remains an a,
a luxury good.
And the people,
it used to paint them or sent to the warehouse where they work for half or a
third of what they,
not half of her,
about a third of what they would make as skilled painters.
They didn't wake up one day,
said,
Jesus,
I can't remember how you paint a plate anymore.
So they said,
no one's going to pay him to paint plates,
except for very special orders.
Glass making.
It's the same thing.
People that,
that,
that made bottles,
that form bottles used to be very well paid.
And then a machine is invented that comes along and,
and,
and does the same thing.
It turns out bottles by the zillions to be filled with wine and whatever.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so they're out of luck.
You know,
the,
as they mad,
they're furious,
and pretty soon they start thinking,
you know,
these unskilled people,
we have some of the same grievances and they begin seeing themselves as a class
apart.
So class consciousness isn't sort of an adventure of,
of lefties from the 1970s,
like your,
yours truly,
it's not at all.
I mean,
it was a reality.
It wasn't for everybody,
but,
but I mean,
if you read a lot of the literature,
especially from,
from,
uh,
you know,
from London or from anywhere about the kinds of solidarities that people had
because of the social class and the sense that they formed a class apart,
uh,
and we're,
we're relegated to sort of,
or permanent proletarian status by forces that they can't control the state and
big money and big capital when people be a little better off.
They are thinking about that now.
But anyway,
that,
that's,
that's that.
Um,
now having said that,
I want to turn in the last 10 minutes to get all that in.
Yes.
I want to turn to,
um,
to,
uh,
something that complements that.
And that is a discussion of,
of industrial discipline.
Because one thing is as,
as workers strike,
as workers learn to strike,
uh,
you know,
going on,
uh,
to,
um,
strike for better working conditions,
uh,
for more money,
for better hours,
shorter hours,
it's Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
one has to imagine,
you know,
what the world looked like from them.
What did they think about things that were happening to them?
And one of the things that had happened to them was this sort of 19th century
end,
uh,
stage of the industrial revolution that is factory production.
Now,
if you were an artisan,
if you were a Taylor or I keep using these,
but are they're so stuck in my mind are artists and a tailor or shoemaker,
you know,
you,
you basically worked,
you know,
when you wanted,
you work in response to I in response to a demand for your product.
Uh,
many of these people were on the move going from one place to the next.
But,
but you worked kind of,
uh,
when you,
when you wanted to or when there was a demand for your product.
If you were in domestic industry and you're a woman working in the hinterland
of,
uh,
Zurich,
you worked when there was demand for your work and then you took time off to
nurse your child,
uh,
or to take account of the family.
Uh,
see how we were doing.
If there was enough to tide through until the next week,
uh,
you more or less worked on your own.
Now a pottery baron called Josiah Wedgwood,
you've probably heard of Wedgewood pottery.
He says just before 1800.
He says,
he's trying to think about how you make all these workers that he has.
How do you make them respond in the very same way so they don't just kind of get
up and wander off or spend time talking or enjoying themselves?
How do you get them all to work at his single command and his dream,
his fantasy was that he wanted a set of workers that responded as singers on two
hands in response to his commands.
That's what he wants.
And he and his successors Caray strategies of doing just that.
And in doing so,
they launched this sort of protracted struggle,
which is very revealing about the bigger processes at play in the 19th century.
And factories have a lot to do with that.
I guess you know,
here,
here too,
when I say that with such intensity for my bad experiences working in factories,
I once,
uh,
I was working in Alice loves jams and jellies and they come up,
come to work about supposed to be there at six in the morning after
a night I probably shouldn't have had.
And the last thing I remember was the guy,
and he didn't like me because I was a college guy.
He say,
I always said my mighty maize and Blue Michigan shirt on.
And he said,
listen to idiot.
The last that I was on jams and jellies,
Jelly duty is there's a huge machine,
like you have to imagine an enormous accordion and enormous accordion.
And they'd put all these berries in there and then the press would squeeze them
into Jelly,
which we would,
we would drink or eat and make ourselves Everly sick.
And there were a lot of pressure.
And the last thing I remember him saying was,
listen to idiot.
Don't leave your,
that was me.
Don't leave your finger on that button.
Very Long.
And as I was trying to figure out,
you know,
who had beaten who the night before,
and the American league in the thing blew up and this enormous tidal wave of
boys and berry juice engulfed me.
And I was burned,
actually.
I was out of,
I was out,
uh,
I was on sick leave for two weeks,
or it's just done playing basketball and getting paid to do that.
And it,
this tidal wave of boysenberries,
uh,
a forklift with about something like 2000 jars of apple butter spun out of
control.
And it was a terrible,
terrible mess.
But the point of this is that I hated the foreman and that factory.
And as I left,
I said,
well,
too bad for you,
for him.
And I didn't have,
I think that about it.
So anyway,
uh,
anyway,
the point of this is that factories become,
first of all,
a way of maintaining industrial discipline.
And that in the first factories in Britain,
they were not there because you had these machines that were there,
uh,
immediately.
James Watts,
uh,
you know,
a steam engine was,
was not used for really about 15 years after it was made.
Uh,
because there were many things it could do.
The first factories were there putting together artisans,
semi-skilled workers,
and unskilled workers as a form of industrial discipline.
And when you think,
if you see postcards,
you know,
at the end of the 19th century,
but in 1900,
the craze for postcards begins in Europe and in the United States too.
And now these postcards are extremely expensive.
If they have people in them,
particularly people at work,
I mean they call it,
they're really,
really,
and I have all sorts of from,
from,
uh,
from the motion,
the portion in industry and from the strikes.
But if you see these pictures,
when workers had their pictures taken together,
they are always in front of the door.
Uh,
and because why?
You had to enter the door or leave the door,
uh,
that the signal was given by the clock and by the bell that called you to work.
And if you were late,
well,
too bad for you,
you could be doctor or fired in there.
Lots more people out there who would like to have those jobs.
And so what happens in the 19th century is that,
is that the factory,
you know,
before really it's,
it's,
it's uh,
um,
it's role as a houser of big fund during machines in many places.
The factory was first and foremost a way of,
of,
uh,
putting discipline on workers.
There's a whole terrible case in Brooklyn,
I think in 1912 or something.
We're 150 or 200 women were burned to death because they had locked the Po.
The bosses had the formative,
locked the doors so they couldn't go out and quote unquote chatter.
And so what they began to do in the middle of the 19th centuries have rules,
regulations for work.
What you can do,
you can't talk,
which,
and when she can't do what you must do.
And if you were a porcelain worker and you,
and something blew up in the oven,
well that was docked from,
from your salary.
And so,
uh,
in order to,
you know,
to watch over these workers,
they bring in the foreman for people to it because there was a strike in the
most because the,
uh,
the,
the format,
the foreperson who a woman was very religious and she made the workers kneel
down on the,
on the,
on the ground and pray on the stone with her knees on the stolen before work
started.
Uh,
no separation of church and,
and work there.
And so they bring in foreman who are going to enforce these,
uh,
to see if what you're a good worker,
if you're a bad worker.
Now workers are present this very much.
Um,
how did workers view the bosses?
For example,
in the 1820 [inaudible] and 1830s,
they tended to,
you know,
you're still working in smaller units of production and most places in Europe,
if you're in a factory and you see the,
you know,
you got an issue with the boss,
the boss is somebody who might give you a little extra on Christmas or something
like that.
Um,
you get the boss is somebody you knew and,
and there was a sense of,
well,
you know,
you're not doing me right now.
This isn't right and I'm going to leave to till you get it together to do better
by me to boss is a presence.
Uh,
he's there all the time as my boss and Dennis uniform manufacturer company also
in Portland,
Oregon.
Uh,
you know,
he was there all the,
all the time.
By the time the foreman start coming in,
it's a foreman is representing the boss and the foreman has somebody who's
brought in from the outside or promoted often unjustly from within.
And the foreman replaces the boss as the one who was hitting on the young female
workers,
what they call them,
French,
the Dwight Acree sash that's rather crude.
Uh,
the,
you know,
the right of hitting on,
uh,
the Eh and s scoring with,
or,
uh,
putting oneself in a power relationship with,
with,
uh,
you know,
with,
uh,
a female employee.
So the foreman begins to represent the boss and the boss.
Now during strikes,
the language of workers during strikes is,
you know,
the boss,
he's a,
he's a latch.
Uh,
he's a drunk.
He eats too much.
He doesn't care whether they live or die.
He's still somebody you see kind of walking through,
walking through and all that.
You don't like him that much,
but,
but you know,
he's still a presence.
The strikes at the end of the 19th century are very,
very different.
The boss often is,
he's a very distant person.
He's sending telegrams from London or sending telegrams from Fox effort,
uh,
to his foreman,
demanding,
demanding this or that.
Uh,
in the case of a strike and Limos,
France,
the,
uh,
the owner of the factory was an American called David [inaudible] Havilland as
an Havilland porcelain.
Uh,
one point actually demands that the u s embassy send in the US Marines,
uh,
to,
it was,
if that was possible in order to put an end to this disturbance,
this disorder in his factory,
he has become,
or she,
a symbol of capitalism protected by the state and protected by the army.
This is the,
this is how workers,
not all workers,
but in many cases view the boss view.
The boss industrial discipline has been,
uh,
has been imposed by these rules,
these regulations,
these foremen.
And if you don't like it,
too bad,
you can't.
Women workers are no longer allowed to go to nurse their children to bring their
children in,
or it could go out and nurse them.
Uh,
they are forced to eat,
you know,
inside the factory.
Uh,
and if you were,
that's why tuberculosis rates are just enormous.
All particularly in mining and in,
in factories.
I mean,
all the kind of adult,
you'll see this in Germany.
Unal it's really kind of amazing book.
Um,
so this is the view of,
of,
of workers of their bosses tells you something about this long process,
very uneven and not everywhere,
but still there.
Uh,
uh,
that explained this massive kind of,
movements of strikes that you found in all sorts of countries in northern Italy,
uh,
in Barcelona,
in,
in Moscow,
the of 1917,
uh,
this huge strikes and it would be terribly important in 1917 in Moscow.
And then,
then something else happens.
And I'm going to end with this because I,
it's a minorly in a minor way.
Amazing Tale about,
about,
uh,
a colleague,
brilliant.
A woman I know called Michelle [inaudible] Ho I something that she wrote in the
late 1970s that it's just still tells you so much about our time in the
beginning of the 20th century in American engineer called Taylor,
g a y l o r comes up,
remember this is time of the Olympics have started up again.
You measure how people,
how fast people can run the hundred or how far they can store the shot.
Put,
you're measuring things,
you're measuring things.
The car races have a gun,
the Po Po,
he Luby bicycle race,
which was a bloody spectacle with bikes careening out of control all the time.
And he's,
you know,
working class heroes getting just mangled,
uh,
in part through each other's manipulations of,
of uh,
trying to knock them off.
But you,
you're measuring things.
And so Taylor comes up with this way of measuring units of production.
The ultimate in industrial discipline.
You are on the assembly line.
They will count the number of units you can do,
um,
of,
uh,
jars of apple butter that you can turn out.
And if you're not turning out enough SIA,
we'll get somebody else.
There are a lot of people want that job.
We'll see you.
That's why they wait to stay down.
Cause there are a lot of people want those jobs because of the growth now.
And he becomes the darling of the French car manufacturers.
Just that end of four,
it becomes the Darlin.
He is a hot item.
Uh,
he would be on people magazine if they did have one,
uh,
because he comes and tells them how they can get more effort out of their tired,
fatigued workers by counting them.
And it just
like that all the way.
And Michelle Hole,
when she wrote a brilliant article that an edited book I did a long time ago,
her book was called,
their article was called the three ages of industrial discipline.
And she had an amazing phrase for the late 1970s.
This is before,
thank God,
cell phones.
And it was before,
uh,
you know,
computers,
personal computers and all of that.
There were computers,
but they weren't personal computers.
Uh,
she said that in this post industrial age where you've got the rust belt and
you've got factories being torn down outside Detroit and in Flint,
in Torrington and water brain,
places like that,
and any Pittsburgh,
and almost anywhere you can name that was the heart of the American industrial
experience.
She predicted in 1978 that what would replace Tara Taylorism would be the
computer that's the computer will measure in your cubicles,
your performance.
And she said in the end,
the,
the foreman would be replaced by the quiet violence of a computer.
Kind of amazing.
See,
on Wednesday.